heute stand die familie vor gericht wie
hat familie eingewirkt auf dich vor
allem nach dem jetzt das rausgekommen
ist dass die mutter sich offenbar
umbringen wollte für die richterin war
das heute morgen erstmal anlass auch ein
bisschen fürsorglich mit dem angeklagten
umzugehen sie sagte er soll nicht immer
so früh vorgeführt werden damit er nicht
so viel den kameras ausgesetzt ist kurz
danach ist dann die mutter sichtlich
äußerlich vom typ her auch verändert in
den saal gebracht wurden eine
begleiterin vom sozialen dienst der
justiz stand ihr zur seite gerade nach
diesen berichten über ihre labile psyche
sie hatte nur noch kurze haare setzte
sich dann auf ihren platz etwa acht
meter von ihrem sohn entfernt ihr sohn
guckte immer wieder zu ihr rüber nicht
die ja auch kurz mal zu sie nicht kurz
zurück und als sie dann einfach ihre
personalien angegeben hat gesagt hat
dass sie auch nicht mehr als lehrerin
arbeitet sondern arbeitslos sei und von
ihrem recht das zeugnis zu verweigern
gebrauch mache ist sie aufgestanden und
ich habe dann von meinem platz ihr
gegenüber gesehen wie sie sich eine
träne aus dem auge gewischt hat dann
ging sie wieder
danach kam der vater der wirkte sehr
viel gefasster im weißen hemd und mit
wildlederschuhen
er sagte dass als rundfunk techniker
arbeiten und dass er als vater sagte
explizit als vater des angeklagten mache
ich von meinem recht das zeugnis zu
verweigern gebrauch und der verzicht auf
jegliche aussagen ist danach nur einen
kurzen blick zu seinem sohn rausgegangen
und das offensichtlichste zeichen der
distanz das zeigte dann die
halbschwester an op sie kamen rein schon
mit verschränkten armen vor der brust
musste zu ihrem platz geführt werden
guckte kein einziges mal zu ihrem bruder
der immer wieder ein wenig hilfe suchen
nach ihrem blick suchte und wollte
überhaupt nichts zu sagen ein nebenklage
anwalt versuchte sie dann noch mit einer
frage irgendwie dazu zu bringen das hat
die richterin unterbunden
und wenn man auch weiß dass alle ihren
oder nur einmal in der haft besucht hat
und gesagt hat sie erträgt den anblick
nicht mehr weil sie sich einfach
distanziert von dem was er getan hat
dann kann man auch verstehen diese
dieser akt interaktion dieser hat heute
gezeigt hat
die familie hat also keine aussage
gemacht aber der ex der halbschwester
hat gesprochen was hat er denn gesagt
und familien nehmen
mario es war vier jahre lang mit ihr
zusammen sie haben einen gemeinsamen
vier jahre alten sohn der offenbar auch
stefan bald als sein lieblingsonkel
bezeichnet hat sie waren auch beim essen
und der fast schwager muss man sagen hat
geschildert dass die stimmung oftmals
drohte zu kippen wenn stefan balje dabei
war sei angenehmer gewesen wenn er nicht
da war flüchtlingskrise war oft ein
thema thema das er nicht arbeiten wollte
dass er gesagt hat er will in diesem
staat nicht arbeiten das lohnt sich
nicht will dann sind sich nicht in
westen nicht irgendwas investieren
er hat ihn oft vor seinem computer
sitzen sehen in irgendwelchen chat foren
wie er sagte auch die militaria in
seinem zimmer viele nehmen auf ein dekor
panzer ein altes schwert lng an der wand
und er hat von zwei vorfällen berichtet
wo das wahre gesicht das aggressive
gesicht des krieges stephan barth für
ihn zum ausdruck kamen einmal nach einer
geburtstagsfeier soll er einen freund
mit einem messer bedroht haben und zum
anderen im supermarkt in klostermansfeld
an der kasse unterhielten sich zwei
mitarbeiter einer pizzeria in einer
anderen sprache und da soll stefan baldi
jetzt sie angefahren haben sie sollten
gefälligst deutsch reden wenn sie in
deutschland sein